this is a great clip here I I uh so
we've done some some kind of heavy and
and dark subjects uh but but this I love
this is the house oversight and reform
committee that a hearing on quote the
evolution of anti-democratic extremist
groups and the ongoing threat to
democracy this was supposed to be it was
designed to be of course an opportunity
to defame conservatives but
representative Nancy mace
flip the script now I've known Nancy
Nace fan
to put it mildly she's one of the
Republicans who signed on for this uh
for this so-called respect Marriage Act
and so I'm I'm not a fan of hers she's
generally a left-leaning republican who
goes along with the Democrats agenda on
so many issues but credit where it's due
she shined in this moment this was a
great moment this was her greatest
moment against one of the most vile and
disgusting trans activists in the
country
um this is because they got a bunch of
activists that they brought in
and one of them is uh Alejandra carabaio
who's a male who identifies as a female
and is an absolute soulless ghoul of a
human being
just an awful awful person
now of course that describes all trans
activists I mean all trans activists are
reprehensible
goblins
they are I mean these are these are the
the most vicious reprehensible people in
the political sphere period every single
one without exception but this one in
particular so let's watch as this kind
of a long clip we'll we'll kind of
follow along uh and we start by Nancy
mace
baiting the Trap so here we go
is rhetoric on social media a problem
and a threat to our democracy Mr Ward
yes absolutely Mr Siegel yes Miss
carabaio yes that's no money yes Miss
Tyler yes yes
um another question I have uh do you
believe that rhetoric targeting
officials with violence for carrying out
their constitutional duties
um as a threat to democracy Mr Ward
Mr seagull
yes
yes
yes
yes
all right thank you very much only a few
weeks after the attempted attack on a
Supreme Court Justice on June 25th one
of the witnesses Alejandra carabayo
tweeted out the following in response to
a decision on abortion overturning Roe v
Wade and I'll quote directly from the
Tweet the six justices who overturned
ROE should never know peace again it is
our civic duty to accost them every time
they're in public they are pariahs since
women don't have their rights these
justices should never have a peaceful
moment in public again I know something
about being accosted the night of
January 5th I was physically accosted on
the streets of DC in Navy yard by a
constituent of mine I fervently blamed
rhetoric rhetoric on social media
rhetoric at public events for being
physically accosted I carry a gun
everywhere I go when I am in my district
and I'm at home because I know
personally that rhetoric has
consequences I've had my car keyed I've
had my house spray painted I had someone
trespass in my house as recently as
August I've been doxxed on social media
about where I live and I've had to add
to security everywhere I go often
because I can't afford it I have to
carry my own firearm wherever I go and
Alejandra carabayo also recently tweeted
on November 19th not even a month ago
that the Supreme Court vested with the
judicial power of the United States by
our Constitution stated they are not a
legitimate Court issuing decisions and
also the Supreme Court is an organ of
the far right so my last question today
of Ms carabayo do you stand by these
comments this kind of rhetoric on social
media
and do you believe it's a threat to
democracy
thank you representative for the
opportunity to clarify and provide
context to my tweets
um I have a question is it yes you know
do you believe your rhetoric is a threat
to democracy when you're calling to a
cost a branch of government the Supreme
Court
I don't believe that's a correct uh
characterization statements did you not
tweet that that you thought that the
Supreme Court Justices should be
accosted
characterization of my statements
uh that's great and what makes it great
too is that we've got carabaio saying
that's not that's an unfair
characterization of my statements
meanwhile his statements are right
behind her right there you can see it
you said you wanted a cost I didn't say
that that's not what I said it's right
there
profiling surveillance data harvesting
there are a lot of things I don't like
about tech Giants but there's only so
much I could do about it I don't have 44
billion dollars to go buying up Twitter
I don't know about you the good news is
that you don't have to be a billionaire
to take a stand for less than seven
bucks a month you can join me and fight
back against big Tech by using
expressvpn big tech companies they make
their money by tracking your online
activity your searches your video
history everything you click on they
sell that data advertisers who Target
you expressvpn helps you anonymize much
of your online presence by hiding your
IP address so they can't match any
activity back to you I use expressvpn on
all my devices to make it much more
difficult for big tech companies to
exploit my data for their own profits
it's incredibly easy to use I just tap
one button on my phone or my computer
and I'm free to roam the internet free
from Big text prying eyes if you don't
like big Tech tracking you and selling
your personal data for profit you can
fight back by using expressvpn visit
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show right now
and get three extra months of expressvpn
for for free that's expressvpn.com Matt
Walsh show expressvpn.com Matt Walsh
show
now
are those is a beautiful moment because
it exposes
the uh of course the hypocrisy and the
double standards and everything and and
but more than that it just exposes
the the hollowness of what these people
say
and that that's really the value
because pointing out double standards it
only goes so far I get that
the value in doing it is that
it shows it demonstrates
um that what these people say is it's
totally Hollow nothing that they say
means anything it doesn't mean anything
all they care about is themselves they
are utterly consumed and this is the
case of leftist activists in general in
particular trans activists they are just
totally consumed by their own egos the
only thing they care about that's it and
so they're going and they want all of
society to revolve around them and to
affirm everything they believe about
themselves and to participate in
whatever delusional uh you know charade
that they demand and they're just gonna
say whatever they feel like they need to
say to to advance that agenda doesn't
mean anything
there are no principles here there are
no there are no underlying principles
I wish that was the case
you know the people that talk about uh
when you say make these statements it's
a threat to democracy and all this like
I I and we used to call these people we
the left is there snowflakes and they're
oversensitive and there's still people
on the right who say that but that that
was never the case I wish it was that I
wish it was just that I wish it was uh
the problem with people on the left is
that someone like carabao
the problem with these people is that
they're overly sensitive and you know
they take words too seriously and uh you
know and they have this almost like
Victorian prudishness when it comes to
language
I wish that was the case
you know I know people who are actually
overly sensitive
and that could it could be a bad thing
it could be a flaw
but it does emanate from it's it's a
sensitivity like you you care about
people that's what I mean if you're
actually sensitive I mean you're
sensitive and caring person
it's not bad to be a sensitive and
carrying person I'm not but it's not bad
to be that
and yeah I can go a little bit too far
sometimes and uh and all of that but
that's not the issue here this is not
about sensitivity this is not about
thinking you know they they want
civility in language
now the real answer that carbio is not
going to give and didn't give there
is that
well no it's okay to call for a costing
Supreme Court Justice because they
deserve to die
like he wants them dead that's it
actually wants them dead
these people they would be happy
if someone actually made it into Brett
Kavanaugh's house the guy who came to
kill if he actually made it into the
house and and murdered him and his whole
family they would be happy they would be
they would be ecstatic
so that's the answer
they deserve to die
anyone who disagrees with them deserves
to die that is their actual belief
and that'll do it for us for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]